saluons se retrouvent donc pour la
dernière vidéo de tous et tuto pour
réussir à résoudre un rubik's cube en
moins de deux minutes avec seulement
cinq formules on a vu ça les six
derniers jours ensemble
aujourd'hui je fais un recap un petit
peu rapide où vous me voyez le résoudre
avec et puis un petit bonus à la fin qui
vous permettra de vous amuser encore
plus avec un rubik's cube
alors évidemment j'aurais pu vous parler
d'autres techniques pour le résoudre
vous apprendrez également plus de
formules vous parlez des finger clic ce
qui est la manière dont on positionne
les doigts pour aller encore plus vite
dans la résolution du remix mais
vraiment le but de ces vidéos c'était de
vous apprendre déjà à le réussir pour
vous familiariser aussi avec un rubik's
cube avec un tout petit peu
d'entraînement en se basant sur les 6
vidéos précédentes
ça vous permet de résoudre ce rubik's
cube une bonne fois pour toute et je
veux que j'arrête de taper avec pour
l'anecdote tout à l'heure j'ai tapé avec
et il sait démonter je vous recommande
d'investir dans autre chose que le
rubik's cube de base il ya les vécu il
ya plein d'autres marques qui en font
prenez des rubik's cube qui tourne bien
déjà ça vous permettra d'aller plus vite
ça vous permettra aussi de ne pas vous
perdre dans les formules et puis
clairement c'est plus agréable
je vais partir de la face blanche comme
ça on va s'y retrouver comme j'ai déjà
un blanc de place et je le gardais là et
je vais chercher celui qui va à côté à
savoir celui ci leblanc thé vert que je
place en face là il faut l'autre ongles
où il ya du verre et qui se situe là
pour le moment donc on va le ramener ici
comme ça j'ai ma première ligne je vais
chercher à la compléter avec le rouge
qui est là voilà et puis un autre angle
celui ci très bien voilà le bleu il
s'est positionné tout seul on va pas
demander plus je vais placer le orange
dans la foulée parce qu'il est pas loin
et ensuite le dernier c'est celui-là ça
c'est ce qu'on avait vu le premier jour
à savoir faire sa première phase avec la
première pour ensuite faut qu'on fasse
correspondre les centres de chaque phase
avec la première couronne ça c'était
quand même le plus facile on avait vu ça
le jour 2 et maintenant on va mettre en
place ces quatre kubla donc ces huit
faces l'ag du vert et du rouge donc je
vais me placer pour l'instant sur le
vert le rouge et or ici il faut que je
l'emmène à gauche donc j'applique la
formule
il me permet d'aller à gauche voilà il
est placé là et je vais commencer à
identifier les autres là j'ai un verre
orange mais c'est très bien je la suis
ici et il me reste le bleu et rouge qui
est là c'est impeccable et là le dernier
ce sera le orange bleu qui doit être ici
exactement toujours avec les formules
qu'on avait vus ensemble le deuxième
jour ce qui nous permet de réaliser donc
la deuxième couronne maintenant on
cherche à avoir la croix
et souvenez-vous là je suis dans mon cas
idéal où j'ai ce petit logo là donc je
le place en haut à gauche par rapport à
moi et je fais le dé et je fais le dé à
l'envers à celle envers allah à l'envers
h à aider pour avoir la croix de
positionner et là ça m'arrange pas dans
la vidéo puisque tout est bien en place
alors attendez je vais casser ça
voila voila j'ai volontairement casser
ça parce que sinon ça me faisait sauter
une technique des fois ça arrive que
tout se mette bien en place ça c'est le
hasard des mélanges de départ donc on a
réalisé la croix maintenant il faut que
les cendres de la troisième couronne
correspondent aussi à la deuxième et
première couronne donc là pour le verset
bon le bleu est en face du rouge le
orange est bon le rouge est en face du
bleu ce n'importe quoi donc je vais
placer le rouge en face du rouge et le m
à ma gauche comme ça le bleu ira lui
devant le orange ira ici et le verre
irhal la formule vous souvenez des
haches d'inverser hdh ya réservé ch4 et
ils sont en classe avant dernière étape
maintenant il faut que je place les
coins au niveau des trois phases qui
correspondent donc ce n'est pas le cas
pour lui c'est pas le cas pour lui
est ce que c'est le cas pour lui non
plus parce qu'il n'ya pas de rouge sans
aucune de ces trois phases et là non
plus donc il n'a aucun bon comme ça
c'est réglé je vais appliquer la formule
gd voilà là je regarde ce que ça donne
ici c'est pas bon ici c'est pas bon ici
c'est pas bon mais ici c'est bon celui
ci je vais le préserver je vais le
sauvegarder en mettant le plus loin de
moi et à ma gauche et leur applique la
formule
je vérifie que tout correspond bien
c'est le cas si ça n'avait pas été le
cas j'aurais encore appliquer la formule
est maintenant on va le terminer ce
rubik's cube grâce à ce qu'on avait vu
déjà auparavant le dhd inversée hdh
carré d'inverser achkhar et à laquelle
on réplique l' inverse de ce qu'on vient
de faire donc bien versé à ch'val cdh
inversée d'inverser achkhar et des
haches car il ne reste plus que ces deux
là donc ceux qui sont bons je les laisse
à ma droite ce que je vais bouger je
l'aimé à ma gauche les deux bleus et je
réplique encore ça et voilà un rubik's
cube de régler si j'avais été un peu
plus vite sans prendre le temps de vous
expliquer de faire les gestes un peu
lentement je l'aurais résolu en moins de
deux minutes après c'est dur de
descendre à moins de deux minutes avec
ces méthodes là et j'ai utilisé que cinq
formules je vous avais promis un petit
bonus avant de partir sachez qu'il
existe des tricks qu'on peut faire avec
donc c'est des figures spéciale avec le
rubik's cube par exemple en mettre un
d'une couleur différente au centre de
chaque face moi je vais vous apprendre à
faire le damier de damier c'est le plus
simple à faire vous allez adorer le
faire il se base sur les 180 degrés vous
prenez une phase vers vous n'importe
laquelle
et vous allez faire un 180 degrés sur
les deux lignes extérieures et les deux
colonnes extérieures peu importe l'ordre
donc ça venait avec clac clac clac clac
et pareil donc fait autant pour les
lignes intérieures et extérieures
là on a un damier ici là non là oui là
non là non la non là non on retourne le
cube un endroit on n'a que des lignes
puisque tout le reste des lignes on met
les lignes en colonnes par rapport à
nous et on applique encore 180 degrés
sur les deux lignes on en est fait de
plus et ça automatiquement fait les deux
dernières fassent ce qui fait que
maintenant on a un magnifique damier et
si je voulais leur passé en cubes de
départ il me suffirait de refaire 180°
six fois à six endroits différents
comme on l'a fait pour le transformer en
damier voilà c'était la dernière vidéo
sur le rubik's cube j'espère vraiment
que ça vous aura plu j'espère que vous
allez vous y mettre
je le disais hier j'ai tourné toutes ces
vidéos début d'avril au youtube space
merci à eux et à toute l'équipe de
m'avoir accueilli et d'avoir mis le
bistrot à disposition pour filmer
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne vous pouvez commenter dans la
vidéo si vous avez des questions à
propos du rubik's cube ou sur d'autres
méthodes ou sur d'autres formules je me
ferai un plaisir de vous y répondre
quand je rentrerai vacances si je suis
en vacances donc rendez vous demain à 17
heures si on est en semaine ou à 11
heures si on est en week-end prenez soin
de vous ciao